So we need something better than this if we want to deal with mutually distrusting parties.
We'll call this protocol 2.
In this protocol, Alice will start by doing 3 things.
She'll pick a value for x. There are 2 possible values--0 and 1.
We can think of 0 as representing heads and 1 representing tails.
She'll also pick some key of 1th n, so this is going to be a random key.
N is a security parameter--the higher the value of n, the larger space of possible keys,
the more secure the protocol will be.
Let's assume we're going to use AES, and we'll make n 128.
Then Alice will compute a message, which is the result of encrypting using the key
the value of x.
She'll send to Bob, the value of m.
Bob receives the value of m--we'll keep track of it--and picks a guess.
Bob will generate, however he wants, a guess valued at either 0 or 1.
That's like calling the coin toss.
Bob will send that guess back to Alice.
Alice knows the values that she picked for x, k, and m
as well as the value Bob picked for the guess.
At this point, Alice sends the key to Bob, and Bob can compute the result of decrypting
with the key--the message.
This is the message that Alice sent to Bob in step 1.
At this stage, Bob can check whether or not he won the coin toss,
comparing the value of t with the value of his guess.
If they're equal, that means Bob guessed correctly and Alice should charge
the Robo-dog. If they're not equal, then it's up to Bob to charge the Robo-dog.
Alice needs to know the winner too.
She could do that.
She could easily do that by checking if the guess is equal to x.
She could also do the decryption because she has the key as well.
So at the end of the protocol, both participants agree on the result of the coin toss.
Now the question is, is this fair?
So the question is, how hard is it for Alice to cheat using Robo-dog Protocol 2?
And by cheat here, we mean gain an advantage--
be able to make the coin toss unfair in her favor.
Here's the choices. There's only 1 correct answer.
It's the easiest thing for Alice to do that would be enough to make the coin toss
unfair for Bob.